hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown Arkansas Senator
Tom cotton was warning Americans to take
the coronavirus seriously in January the
Republican lawmaker joins host Jessica
Rosenthal to discuss what Congress must
do to address Kovan 19 the nation's
economic crisis and bringing
pharmaceutical manufacturing back to
America also health officials are
issuing warnings about reopening
economies too quickly monica crowley
assistant secretary of the treasury for
public affairs joins host dave Anthony
to discuss the plan to help Americans
struggling financially
amid the pandemic Plus commentary from
Fox News contributor and radio host
Lesley Marshall the Fox News rundown is
a Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com Tammy Bruce I'm Juan
Williams i'm shannon bream and this is
the fox news rundown
[Music]
Wednesday May 13 2020
I'm Jessica Rosenthal the short-term
fight against the virus involves money
masks and testing but the long-term
fight might involve some moving we can
never allow China to continue to have
such a stranglehold on so many critical
supplies to keep our people safe healthy
and prosperous I'm Dave Anthony House
Democrats are pushing three trillion
dollars in new economic stimulus and the
money approved earlier well it's been
going out to more smaller businesses
lately that was the intention of the
program to make sure that the
mom-and-pop shops that make America so
great and are the beating heart of this
economy we're taking care of and have
the resources that they need and I'm
Leslie Marshall I've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
one of the big metrics in the fight
against the virus has been testing for
it
not just for the heck of it but to self
quarantine our isolate if one is
positive some of the countries that seem
to have fared better than others with
kovat 19 got on testing fast early and
they were able to test many people we in
the US had some delays in testing we
know this and we know that it set us
back but since the earlier days of the
pandemic we've ramped up testing and
private companies and labs created their
own tests now the u.s. is leading and
testing according to White House
spokeswoman Kaylee mcenany the u.s. now
leads the world in testing for weeks the
media cited South Korea as being the
gold standard for testing but as it
stands we are now testing at a higher
rate per capita than South Korea and in
fact as this chart is going to show you
in all 50 states we are now testing at a
higher rates per capita than South Korea
testing is silica focus elsewhere
reuters reported this week that after a
small handful of cases were detected in
Wuhan China officials there said they'd
be testing all 11 million residents
Wuhan is of course where evidence shows
the virus outbreak began and despite
apparent efforts from China to downplay
the virus that couldn't hide the
entirety of their reaction and that is
what caught the attention of one senator
now leading the charge against China I
could tell early on in January that
China's rhetoric that they were in
control and the virus was not a threat
and there's no cause for alarm
contrasted with their Taccone in'
extreme measures to counteract the virus
Arkansas Senator Tom cotton like
cancelling schools nationwide are
literally welding the door shut on
apartment buildings that's what sells
the alarms to me early on but for as
long as I've been in public life I've
recognized China is a grave threat to
United States you know with an ultimate
mission to replace us as the world's
preeminent economic and military power
so some of the measures I've proposed
like trying to keep Huawei that Chinese
telecom giant that is effectively an arm
intelligence out of Western telecom
systems are long-standing now I've
introduced new measures related this
virus for instance trying to bring back
pharmaceutical manufacturing to the
United States and other measures that
are designed more broadly the Chinese
and missions in the western Pacific and
around the world and that's because
China is the most serious long-term
threat the country basis to our security
and prosperity when we talk about
bringing pharmaceutical manufacturing
back how delicate a process is that and
do we run the risk of China saying oh
you're you're gonna go ahead and do that
well we're just gonna stop making the
medications you need right now so China
is already threatening those kinds of
actions against many nations threatening
to withhold either drugs or needed
protective equipment formation and if
for instance they don't agree to use
Huawei in their generation Wireless
build out or just refusing to send
protective equipment to a country unless
the head of state goes and meets the
Chinese airplane and Cal tails on tarmac
for the cameras so we have to be mindful
that in the short term we the world is
somewhat dependent not entirely but
somewhat dependent on China
so both drugs and medical equipment but
that's why in the medium and especially
the long term we can never allow China
to continue to have such a stranglehold
on so many critical supplies to keep our
people safe healthy and prosperous where
are you though on our own mistakes it
seems like we did make quite a few here
China or not whether that was you know
not maybe having enough equipment on our
own stockpile to our own testing delays
and failures including unbelievably our
own tests some of which were tainted
with the actual virus yes a bit of
course I would commend the president for
taking an action that was considered
very controversial at the time of
stopping air travels in China and late
January I advocated for that since the
middle of January when I first started
contrasting Chinese rhetoric to action
that bodice 76 of needed time they did
the same thing with Europe as well I
mean it wasn't foolproof it wasn't ever
going to stop the virus
reaching United States and certainly
bought time you're right that probably
the worst of the state the federal
bureaucracy has made is when the Centers
for Disease Control insisted on doing
its own tests manufacturing its own
tests from scratch rather than if you
will letting a thousand flowers bloom
and some of our great laboratories and
companies all around the world the FDA
as well allowed the students to do that
and then was slow on certifying other
possible tests in early February that's
regrettable and in though the challenge
that we have had is not so much a
science challenge about developing the
right kind of test the trip reduction
challenge of being able to develop
testing equipment for a nation of three
hundred and thirty million people as
opposed to say you know Australia with a
nation of eight million people or Taiwan
and island nation of 22 million people
but over time we we have begun to meet
that challenge that's why now on a
per-capita basis we have one of the best
records in the country for testing but
it it would have been better early on a
force people have died look at how many
people have died since then I mean do
you think testing could have made a big
difference Joe I think the lessons that
we've seen from countries around the
world that testing can help slow the
spread of the virus and therefore help
protect the capacity of our hospital
systems which again is the reason why we
instituted such severe measures in March
related social distancing but in the end
the virus is so highly contagious in so
many different settings testing can only
do so much it's better to have more
testing than less testing especially
testing at sites that are most
vulnerable like nursing home sites or
critical infrastructure that can only
engage in a limited amount of social
distancing given the necessities of work
like meatpacking plants so testing it is
very important in those places but in
the end even the nation's that have had
the best approach to testing especially
in Europe you still see pretty
significant numbers of cases and
on a per capita basis and sadly that's
just a reflection of the very highly
contagious and very deadly nature of the
virus for some populations states are
starting to reopen as you know some
allowing more than others this is
apparently changing the models
I guess yet again University of
Washington's Institute for Health
metrics and evaluation is now estimating
that about 137 thousand people could die
from kovat and I think a lot of us don't
really know what to say anymore about
these models changing right like if
you're for reopening because you care
about livelihoods and jobs and you're
accused of being okay with letting
people die and then you hear you know
far more people may die because we're
increasing mobility and it's just it's
like where everybody is between a rock
and a hard place like what do we do here
well I've never been a big fan of any of
the models not say that models can't be
useful for decision-making but they're
always based a group to degree on
speculation as opposed to hard
information so I've heard look at the
hard data we have a lot of data now that
we didn't have two months ago not just
from the United States in places like
New York that were particularly hard yet
but also from Europe and you see
countries that that will get with the by
RS a few weeks before we were there now
been a few weeks ahead of us in terms of
getting their economy back on its feet
and so far seems to be working for them
in places like Austria and Denmark and
Germany as well so I think we should
learn as much as we can from those
international models and also our
examples not models I should say and
then also you know kind of gradually
move forward with getting our economy
back on its feet getting people back to
work getting them back in their normal
routines obviously if there's a big
surge in cases somewhere that might
cause us to recalibrate or pull back on
the reins a little bit but it's finally
important that we get people back to
work back into their normal routines
because the government cannot replace
the economy and without a healthy strong
functioning economy people are at risk
not just at their livelihoods also their
health as well you know they're
foregoing basic treatments like
mammograms or colon strangers yeah they
are in many cases suffering from mental
health challenges or stress related to
family
in the workplace and so forth so the
health and the economic questions are
more interconnected than much of the
media commentary would suggest and we
had to keep both those thank you Mike
senator when we talk about reopening and
we look at a model country like South
Korea they're experiencing and
increasing cases and we kind of thought
they had had mastered this right but but
now they're starting to see some more
with contract tracing now they're
they're trying to notify over 1500
people after one infected person visited
a number of bars and nightclubs in one
evening this I mean I think this speaks
want the importance of contract tracing
I guess and knowing who's infected and
to how one person can do just so much
damage and an up end though the work
that you do when you try and isolate for
a while and you know obviously South
Korea has been one of the leading
examples in the world along with Taiwan
for keeping the virus under control so
I'm troubled by the resurgence and cases
they are over the last couple days I
certainly hope that they get it under
control again
you say the same thing happened in
Singapore in April they had been a world
leader as well in March and then they
had a large flare-up in April that I
think is continuing it's just a reminder
that no matter how much testing there is
how much contact tracing the virus is so
contagious and there's still so much we
don't know about it finally senator on
stimulus you know there's still a lot of
talk that even more is needed as we as
we work slowly towards getting back to
normal I know some Democrats want to
give a lot more money to people we've
already give Congress has already
allocated almost three trillion the
president's talking about a payroll tax
cut our governor in California says four
and a half million people are unemployed
and we had a budget surplus that is now
a massive deficit where are you on
stimulus and how much more we're going
to give and and whether or not we could
give any to states and counties so the
Congress has already proved about three
billion dollars or three trillion
dollars of spending to help survive the
peak of this crisis a lot of that money
though hasn't gone out the door and
hasn't yet the pockets of individual
workers in the case of hand
unemployment benefits which are approved
with the nwi or money to aid state local
governments or to help our hospital
systems so I think for the time being
there's enough money still in the
pipeline for us to see how that works
and the whole plate you know within a
matter of weeks not months we will begin
to see people getting back something
more like their normal work and
consumption routines and that it won't
be necessary to have trillions of
dollars of more spending to replace the
productive economic activities of our
citizens in the end I think most people
don't want a relief check they want to
paycheck and that's where I hope we'd
get very soon matter of weeks not in a
matter of months senator Kahn thank you
so much for your time
[Music]
this is leslie marshall with your fox
news commentary coming up doctors on the
white house coronavirus task force made
a house call to the senate wrapping
extensive and widely available timely
testing is essential for reopening
America though CDC director dr. Robert
Redfield FDA Commissioner dr. Steve Hahn
and dr. Anthony Fauci weren't actually
there they appeared by a video each in
quarantine for having contact with
someone who has the corona virus there
is no doubt even under the best of
circumstances when you pull back on
mitigation you will see some cases
appear but dr. Fauci warned if states do
too much too fast you will trigger an
outbreak and you may not be able to
control which in fact paradoxically will
set you back not only leading to some
suffering and death it could be avoided
but could even set you back on the road
to trying to get economic recovery and
while Democrats thank to the doctor for
his guidance they took shots at the
president senator patty Murray calling
the White House response disastrous fact
of the matter is President Trump has
been more focused on fighting against
the truth than fighting this virus and
Americans have sadly paid the price
Republican senator Lamar Alexander who
chaired Tuesday's hearing by video also
in quarantine after staffer got the
virus said reopen we must staying at
home indefinitely is not the solution to
this pandemic there's not enough money
available all those hurt closed already
the federal government has spent a
record amount to help Americans 30
million have filed for an employment in
just the past six weeks obviously we're
in an unprecedented situation we have
never faced anything like this before
where the government has actually
mandated a nationwide economic shutdown
Monica Crowley is assistant secretary of
the Treasury for public affairs there
was an understanding very early on that
because the government was shutting it
down the government was going to also
have to provide the solution and the
government was going to have to step in
and fill that void so we had a series of
pieces of legislation come through be
signed into law by the president that
yes
are very expensive require a lot of
money trillions and trillions of dollars
where does this money come from
Treasury bonds is that essentially what
it is that the US is selling Treasuries
and that's what's funding all this it's
not a certainly part of it yes the
Federal Reserve has stepped in and they
are providing trillions of dollars in
liquidity I think it's about four to
five trillion dollars in liquidity as
well through special vehicle special
facilities as we call them that have
been stood up to transfer a lot of these
funds to where they need to go under the
legislation all right now let's go
through some of the things that have
happened including the checks that went
out 1200 for an individual 2,400 for a
married couple for most Americans have
the majority of people gotten these
these payments yes the economic impact
payment
we're stood up within the space of about
two weeks and we were able to as of
today we're able to get out about 130
million
payments $1,200 each more if you have
dependent children and we were able to
do it because we have mechanized a lot
of this via direct deposit so if you
filed your tax returns and have your
direct deposit information on file with
the IRS so every year you can get your
refund I hope that information having
been there those payments were able to
go into your bank account immediately we
are now in the phase of paper checks for
those who do not have the direct deposit
information on file and by the way I
just want to point out that this is the
last opportunity you can go to irs.gov
click on get my payment to input your
direct deposit information and get your
checks right away if you don't do that
by Wednesday of this week then you will
get your money but it will come in the
form of a paper check if you haven't
gotten it already you will get it
obviously there's a lot of work to get
the the Paycheck protection program
money out as well as a lot of
to try to help businesses there's where
are we on the second version of this I
know that was replenished the fund how
much of that fund is still left of the
PPP fund okay so there were two
transfers of money the first tranche was
350 billion second tranche was about 310
billion and we we have since April 27th
when the second tranche began flowing
out again when we relaunched the program
after getting the money appropriated by
Congress we have appropriated about one
hundred and eighty eight billion dollars
of that 310 so there is still plenty of
money left for small businesses it can
protect their workers and keep them on
the payroll and to cover acceptable
overhead like mortgage rent utilities
and so on in order for the loans to be
forgivable though keep in mind 75% of
the money needs to go to payroll cover
their workers it's called a paycheck
protection program so we want small
businesses to protect their workers and
and have this money to bridge them over
this period of time eight weeks and then
the additional 25% is like I said for
that acceptable overhead and then if you
meet those and bring the documentation
to your lender who gave you a loan to
begin with you that loan will be
forgiven so it's more of a grant been
alone all right now there are also some
confusion I've been reading in different
stories for some companies wondering if
they are eligible so you have to make a
certification when you go to an approved
lender you have to make a certification
that you are indeed a small business you
have to show documentation about your
payroll and how many employees you have
so that you have to prove that you're
eligible to participate in this loan
program
fewer than 500 workers right is that
correct fewer than 500 employees that's
correct yes and what we're seeing now to
Dave is that in the first tranche of
money the average loan going out was
about a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars to one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars I believe now the
average loan size is about seventy to
seventy three thousand dollars so
loan sizes are coming down meaning that
these small business loans are actually
going to the smallest of small
businesses businesses with five
employees or less and really that was
the intention of the program to make
sure that the mom-and-pop shops that
make America so great and are the
beating heart of this economy we're
taking care of and have the resources
that they need so this program has been
a big success and what we have seen know
early on was that there were some larger
companies that had additional sources of
liquidity bigger companies or public
companies that had plenty of money
frankly or other sources of liquidity
that we're trying to get in on this and
secretary minutiae made it very clear
that know if you have these additional
sources of liquidity you should not be
in the PPP process you should not be
trying to get these loans so you saw a
number of businesses Ruth's Chris
Steakhouse with a famous one
potbelly there were some others I don't
mean to single them out because there
were plenty who realized that they were
not supposed to be part of this program
and returned the money and so we had
billions of dollars then come back into
the pot that's now being distributed to
small businesses that have gone through
this process of applying and certifying
their eligibility more companies are
considering giving up the loans and
there are reports of confusion about the
rules they claim have been changed along
the way by Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin for instance what about
businesses that have fewer than 500
employees but are publicly traded some
of those companies believe that makes
them ineligible and have paid it back
others do not and plan to keep it so we
asked Monica Crowley to clarify we say
that it is unlikely that a public
company with substantial market value
and access to capital could make the
required certification in good faith and
if they do they should be prepared to
demonstrate to the SBA the basis for the
certification but we don't say
unequivocally that they can't do PPP it
depends on the circumstances so I
understand that companies that may
decide to give back the money and not
keep the loans are on deadline and have
to give it back by tomorrow and if they
do they won't face any penalties that is
correct so if the safe harbor was
extended to through this Thursday and if
you have the money and hold on to it and
do not pay it back
you could be open to investigation and
possible criminal liability Tuesday
afternoon House Democrats unveiled their
plan to hand out three trillion dollars
in more economic stimulus planning a
vote on it Friday
now Senate Republicans have said they'd
like to wait till maybe June to let the
earlier packages keep working House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi says the hunger
doesn't take a pause the rent doesn't
take a pause the hardship doesn't take a
pause and she says not acting is the
most expensive course Democrats call
their bill the heroes Act and want to
provide state and local governments a
trillion dollars they propose another
round of checks for Americans 1200 bucks
per family member up to five two hundred
billion in hazard pay to essential
workers and extending $600 a week extra
unemployment checks till January but all
that may not go anywhere in the Senate
as talks with President Trump continue I
want to see a payroll tax cut I want to
see various things that we want I want
the workers to be taken care of but we
are talking about that we're negotiating
with the Democrats we'll see what
happens now a payroll tax cut could help
both workers and their employers since
they both pay that tax it's unclear how
big any reduction would be or how long
it might last
there was one that started in 2011 after
the recession then that gave workers 2%
of their income back for two years the
president has been very interested in a
payroll tax holiday and he believes that
it will further stimulate the economy on
the president the vice-president
secretary minuchin have all talked about
a strong rebound in the third quarter
and really a very powerful continuing
rebound into the fourth quarter
into next year and the President
believes that a payroll tax holiday will
well further add juice to the economic
engine once we emerge fully from this
crisis I think that what you've seen on
the hill is some pushback particularly
from Republicans on that but also
Democrats are not all that interested in
it so from a legislative standpoint
we'll have to see where it goes but the
president has talked a lot about that
and I do know that he's got advisors
around him who also believe in in the
power of that to help American workers
Monica Crowley assistant secretary of
the Treasury for public affairs thank
you so much for joining us it is my
great pleasure thank you so much for
having me Dave it's the latest from Fox
News podcasts to campaign with Bret
Baier with updates from reporters on the
trail and in studio experts Bret keeps
you informed on the 20/20 race go to Fox
News podcast.com and download the
campaign with Bret Baier now Rayden
review the Fox News rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen it's
time for your fox news commentary what's
on your mind
former vice president and now
presumptive Democratic 2020 presidential
nominee Joe Biden has been accused by
Tara Reid a former staff assistant who
worked in the then senator's office 27
years ago of sexual assault he's done an
interview with MSNBC's Mika Brzezinski
and in that interview the former vice
president said he is innocent I quote
know it never happened unequivocally
after an additional interview that
misery did with megyn kelly online the
vice president doubled down no it never
happened unequivocally I believe Joe
Biden and here's why I am a woman a
feminist and the mother of a preteen
girl who knows that there are
differences between rape sexual assault
and sexual harassment and sadly I have
been the victim of all three I like the
former vice president believed that when
a woman comes forward with claims
sexual misconduct against anyone you
believe her but then you investigate you
go through a vetting process to find the
truth
first we must look at a few things aside
from my opinion in 2016
President Trump who himself has a long
list of accusations against him brought
in some of former President Clinton's
accusers to sit in on a debate when he
was running against Hillary Clinton the
wife of the former president why didn't
Donna Trump attack Joe Biden with this
information the way he did with Hillary
Clinton's husband's accusers claims and
attacking her with that when Blasi Ford
made the claims against Brett Cavanaugh
Donald Trump mocked her publicly and why
have all of the media been timid about
this well I think I know why and I think
it's because Ms Reid is not a credible
witness first there are huge
inconsistencies a year ago she told a
reporter that when she was a staff
assistant in 1993 she said that Joe
Biden touched her shoulder and neck in a
way that made her feel uncomfortable but
then that story change to Joe Biden
sticking his hand out to her skirt and
forcibly penetrating her with his
fingers it takes a lot to come forward
so why would she then change her
accusation a year later her claims that
she made a complaint to the Senate
personnel office well no one's been able
to find that complaint no one's been
able to corroborate that perhaps for me
the two biggest reasons I questioned the
authenticity of this specific accusation
are Reid cannot remember the date time
or exact location of the incident she's
only said that she was delivering a gym
bag to former Vice President Biden
somewhere in the Capitol that's
according to what she told The
Washington Post now as I mentioned
earlier in this piece I've been the
victim of rape assault and harassment
now I can understand someone not
remembering the date or the day of the
week or perhaps the exact time but the
location I am sorry I am most victims I
know I've spoken with remember the
location vividly as that terrible
nightmare replays in our minds over and
over and over throughout
the years and also something very
unsettling for me was miss reads praise
of her alleged assault er she publicly
praised yo Biden for his work on the
Violence Against Women Act she did this
not just once but on multiple occasions
as a victim I would never praise my
attackers what I'd like to do to them is
something straight out of a scene from
The Sopranos but certainly not praise
former vice president has requested that
the National Archives release any record
they have of reads claims put it out he
said although they won't and I agree if
the truth is truly what we're after put
it out there please put it out i'm
leslie marshall you've been listening to
the fox news rundown and stay up to date
by subscribing to this podcast at fox
news podcasts comm and for
up-to-the-minute news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes